Hi.
My name is Jiang Wu.
I'm a professor at
the East Asian Studies
at the University of Arizona.
Today, we're very happy
to have Mr. Bill Porter.
And Mr. Bill Porter
is the author
of several bestsellers of
Chinese culture and religion.
And he also is a translator
of many Chinese poems
and Buddhist scriptures.
And in 2008, he
published Zen Baggage.
It was the instant
success in both China
and the English-speaking world.
And today, we're going
to focus on this book,
and discuss the meaning
of Zen Buddhism,
and also Chinese religion,
in the past 30 years.
And now, Bill, I just want
to start with your book.
OK.
And this book is
a great success.
And as the author, can
you describe, for us,
what kind of book it is,
and what kind of a message
you want to convey
to your readers?
Well, it's more of
a personal account.
My books tend to be
ways of teaching myself.
I write a book to learn.
And so, I wanted to deepen my
understanding of Zen, or Chan,
as it's called, now, in China.
And so, I'm not a writer.
But I learned to write for radio
stations in Taiwan and Hong
Kong, as a travel writer.
That is, I would take
a trip, and come back
to Hong Kong or Taiwan, and
do travel-related programs.
And so, I learned
to write like that.
And so, when I thought about
doing a book about Zen,
I thought I would do
it as a travel book,
and to travel through
Chinese geography,
and also through time, to
China's history of Zen.
And I would begin with the
beginning of Zen in China,
and end with the
sixth patriarch.
The first six patriarchs of
Zen were the most important
in the development.
And so I visited
the sites associated
with each of these six teachers,
and wrote about my own trip
in visiting these places, my own
impressions, my own feelings.
And then, I would
interview Zen masters,
in each of these places,
about their lives,
and about their practice.
And so, it was
that kind of book.
It was sort of like a
personal travel narrative,
along with brief outlines of the
history of Zen in each place.
And also, it begins
with a reflection
on the nature of
Zen, and on language,
especially because Zen is
sort of unique among religions
in the world in disdaining
language-- or at least
recognizing that
language is more
of a problem than a solution.
And so, that's what I did.
So first of all, you
advise we read your book
as a personal account of
your travel experience.
That's right.
Yeah.
And again, it's a travel that's
not just through geography,
but also through Zen.
OK.
So why travel is so
important for you
to understand Zen Buddhism?
I don't think travel is.
I think I could just as
easily understand Zen
without traveling.
But this was also a book that
I envisioned as introducing
Westerners to Zen.
And so, I was trying to, as you
might say, learn more about it
myself, but also record
it in a way that would
be instructive to Westerners.
So I could begin at
the beginning of Zen,
with Bodhidharma,
and take readers
through the history
of Zen, and also,
at the same time taking them
through the geography of China,
and why things developed
in certain places the way
they did.
So the geography is very
important in your understanding
of a Chinese Buddhism,
and Zen Buddhism.
Well, especially in Zen.
Of course, geography plays a
crucial role in the development
of any civilization.
And Chinese
civilization developed
along the Yellow River.
And once there was
a civilization,
a wealthy civilization, they
developed trade connections
with the Mediterranean
via the Silk Road.
And the Silk Road ended
along the Yellow River.
And, so when Buddhism
first arrived,
it arrived in the Yellow River
capitals, Luoyang, and nearby,
in Chang'an.
But there was no Zen
Buddhism at that time.
Zen didn't show up
until around 500 AD.
But when it did,
the first teacher
went up to the Yellow
River, but was not
very successful-- Bodhidharma.
And his own disciple, the
second patriarch, Huike,
was not that successful either.
But there was a religious purge
in China, at a certain time,
and the second patriarch had
to leave the Yellow River,
and go down to the Yangtze.
And then, he taught somebody.
And then, he went back up to
the north, and was assassinated.
But that person he taught--
the third patriarch--
had two disciples.
And one of them became
the fourth patriarch.
And up to this time, Zen
had been a very limited
religious tradition.
The teachers each had only
a handful of disciples.
But with the fourth patriarch,
he had 500 disciples.
And his major
disciple had 1,000.
And his major disciple
had 3000, and so forth.
And so, zen makes this explosion
in the sixth and seventh
century, with the
development of the idea
of practicing a spiritual
tradition in a commune.
There had never been this sort
of communal practice in China
before.
There were a few attempts
by some early Taoists,
but they didn't last long.
But when you see Zen
develop, it develops
along the Yangtze in
an ecological niche
that I would call the
high mountain basin.
Maybe, sometimes,
it wasn't that high.
But it was a mountain basin.
That is, instead of
building your monastery,
and having your disciples
live on a mountain
side, or a mountain top, or
at the foot of the mountain,
or even in an urban
setting, instead of that,
you locate your religious center
in a mountain basin, where
you have hundreds of acres
of flat, arable, well-watered
farmland.
And thus, you develop a
community of practitioners
who live and practice together.
So up until the
fourth patriarch,
Zen was simply the practice you
do on the meditation cushion.
And Zen, of course, the original
meaning of the word "zen,"
was "zenna."
So it's from the
Sanskrit, "dhyana."
And when it came to China,
people would say "zenna."
And then, later, they got rid
of the "na," and became "zen."
But the original approach
to this tradition was just,
Zen is simply sitting
in meditation.
But suddenly, you get
this community develop.
And then, Zen becomes your way
of life-- washing the dishes,
working in the fields,
walking around,
taking a hike in the
mountains, watching the moon.
Your whole way of
life becomes Zen.
And this is what gave Chinese
Zen its distinctive flavor.
Because we don't even
know about Zen in India.
It was such a small sect,
we don't know, even,
if it existed.
Some scholars think it
never existed in India.
But it's very hard
to prove something
exists when there's only a
couple of people doing it.
And probably,
Bodhidharma, Zen probably
would not have been
noticed in China
if it was just Bodhidharma, and
Huike, the second patriarch.
But once you get
these big communities,
of 500, 1,000 people,
you get a major impact
on Chinese culture.
Exactly.
Yeah.
And I think this is what I
wanted to show in this book
that I was writing, of how Zen
developed, coming from people
who were great in their
meditation practice,
but had very little impact
outside of that practice.
Of course, once the
fourth patriarch developed
this community, their
disciples wanted
to respect their teachers,
and their teacher's
teacher, the teacher's teacher.
And so, these early
figures in Zen
become more famous-- like
Bodhidharma, and Huike.
But when they were
alive, they were not
famous at all-- barely noticed.
So we can see, actually,
you're y Chan Buddhism
monks take advantage of
geography, and transportation.
So when they choose
a good location,
actually, their sect or religion
can develop much faster.
Now, that's true.
And by locating in these
mountain basins, when
there are wars, everything
is swept, on the plains,
by armies.
But up in the mountains,
they're left alone.
So if there are local
bandits, or wars going on,
these zen centers
were not affected.
In fact, they were,
themselves, small armies.
Right.
Because you have 500, 1,000
people living together,
they could defend themselves.
Yeah.
So you have a very deep
understanding of Zen Buddhism.
And before and after
the travel, did
you find your understanding
of Zen changed?
Or do you have a
very short definition
about what is Zen Buddhism?
Again, students can memorize,
to take exam, to write it down.
I know it's hard,
but try your best.
Well, again, Zen is
a spiritual tradition
that encourages
its practitioners
to free themselves of concepts.
And because you're
becoming free of concepts,
you're also becoming
free of language.
And so, for me to use
language to define--
That's why I say it's hard.
It's like a fly trying
to get off fly paper.
I'm just going to get stuck.
And so, sometimes,
people would define Zen
as pointing to the moon.
And the teacher's
teaching of Zen
would be the finger
pointing to the moon.
But Zen is the moon, and not
the finger pointing to the moon.
And so, Zen is a tradition that
developed all kinds of ways
to try to get people
to look at the moon.
And, of course, the
moon is their mind.
The moon is simply your mind.
But how does a teacher get
you to look at your mind?
Because we don't necessarily
think that our mind
is important at all.
We just go about our life.
We want to feed our
belly, and do some work,
and make some money,
live in a house
so we don't get rained on.
We don't think about our mind.
But in Buddhism,
everything is mind.
You can't get away
from your mind.
But to realize this
in your daily life,
from the time when you
get up in the morning,
to the time you go to
bed, takes some practice.
And so, Zen developed
ways of practicing.
Of course, meditation
is an important one.
But also living together
with other people who
are practicing,
reading a few books.
A few books can be helpful
in pointing the direction.
But again, these are all
just fingers-- fingers
pointing to the moon.
And eventually, when the
teacher thinks you're ready,
the teacher tries to instruct
you to go further-- that is,
to go directly to your own mind.
And so, probably the most
famous kind of instruction
is have a cup of tea.
Right.
Instead of saying Zen is
this, and this, and this,
Zen is, have a cup of tea.
And then, the teacher
tells you, taste the tea.
So Zen is tasting the tea.
It's something
only you can know.
And so, this is what
I could tell students.
Zen is an attempt to
get people to experience
their own awareness.
So it's an ongoing process.
It is.
Yeah.
And every teacher is going
to approach it differently.
Exactly.
Yeah.
So in the '70s, when you
first study, or learn,
Zen Buddhism, Chinese
Buddhism, you studied with monk
from Wutai Shan, you mention
in your book, called Shou Ye.
Is this the kind of Zen
practice he told you?
He was a Hawaiian monk,
but he was from Wutai Shan.
And I met him in New
York City, in Chinatown.
I was studying anthropology
at Columbia, then.
And I met him, and
every weekend he
had a meditation retreat
in the countryside.
And so, I started joining
him on the weekends.
And I really was
impressed with that.
And I found meditation much
more interesting than working
on a PhD in anthropology.
Indeed.
And so, I gave that
up and went to live
in a monastery in Taiwan.
But Shou Ye was the first
practicing Buddhist I ever met.
And I was very impressed
with him-- the way he taught,
his demeanor.
He was not austere.
He was very happy-- a happy man.
He liked to laugh.
And so, I said, that's the
kind of teacher I can admire.
Sure.
So we can imagine
how powerful he was.
He was.
He persuaded you.
Yeah.
He did.
And also in your
book, you mention
you interviewed so many Zen
teachers and practitioners
in China.
So did you find that, actually,
they practice Zen Buddhism
sincerely, generously?
Are there any teachers
who, according
to your understanding,
actually is a real Zen master?
Oh, yeah.
Of course.
Probably the greatest Zen
master of the last 100 years
was Hsu Yun-- Empty Cloud.
Empty Cloud, yes.
And he had a number of
disciples who also became
really great Zen masters.
Master Jing Hui, who died
a couple of years ago.
And master Fo Yuan, who died
about five or six years ago.
I'd say those were probably
the two most important, or most
powerful Zen teachers I met.
And also, in Hong Kong,
[INAUDIBLE], Master
[INAUDIBLE].
All three of those,
they were all disciples,
and they were all personal
attendants, of Empty Cloud.
When they were young
monks, they all
served as the
attendant of Hsu Yun.
And so, learned from Hsu Yun.
So Hsu Yun's influence is
really strong in China,
and in the world of Zen.
He taught a lot of people.
And a lot of his disciples
became great teachers.
And they're still alive.
But the main thing is,
his disciples were also
good teachers.
And they instructed
a lot of people.
And so, that's why, today,
when you go to China, Zen
is very much alive and well.
In fact, perhaps, it's never
been in better condition.
Of course, there's two different
ways of looking at Zen.
There's the actual
practice, and then
there's the material
outer appearance,
you might say-- the
monastery, the nunnery.
And China's become
such a wealthy country.
And so many Chinese
are Buddhists.
They have been donating lots
of money to monasteries.
And Zen monasteries
have received
millions, and millions,
and millions of dollars
every year, from
different benefactors.
Sometimes it's just
the local farmers,
or the local Buddhists,
but it's also
billionaires have donated
significant amounts of money
to the reconstruction
of monasteries.
You could say this is
good, and this is also bad.
Because you get money, you
can build a nice monastery,
and you can have rooms with,
maybe, only one person in it,
instead of 10.
And you can also have hot water.
So you could take a hot shower.
And you have great food.
So the living conditions in Zen
monasteries is incredibly good.
But, of course, because
they're built like palaces,
you get tourists
coming every day, too.
And this can be very disturbing
for religious practice.
And so, in a sense, there's a
religious Renaissance going on,
in China-- not only in Zen,
but in all factors of religion.
I tell people it this way.
This is my humorous
way of describing it.
I say, the second
thing a Chinese person
does when they become rich is
they send it to the next life.
The first thing you do is
you take care of your family.
But the second
thing is you send it
to your family in the next life.
And the place you do this
is your local monastery
or nunnery, or the
shrine-- local shrine.
These are the places that
have the money transfer codes.
If you go to the
monastery, they have
a way of sending your
merit on to the next life.
So wealthy people have been
giving their large sums
of money to these places,
with the hope that they're
gaining a lot of merit, and this
merit will do them some good
in the next life.
And again, and
this is a problem.
Maybe, about 10 years
ago, it was a good thing.
But it's now
getting to the point
where it's not
necessarily a good thing.
Because the people who are
in charge of a monastery
have to be very careful
when they accept this money.
It can really, actually,
destroy the way of life
they have created,
because then, they
have to accept all of these
visitors coming there.
It's a big problem.
Sure.
I can understand
what do you mean.
Because recently, I
visited the Shaolin Temple,
and met Abbot Shi Yongxin.
AND there's a lot of
controversy surrounding
Shaolin Temple, because
they face exactly
the same problem you mention.
Well, Yongxin has come
up with a solution.
What he does is he says,
well, we have Shaolin Temple.
There's nothing we
can do about it.
So we'll take the money we
get, and we'll use that money
to build practice temples.
Right.
And so, that's what
he's been doing.
In the countryside, he's been
building small temples, where
maybe about 20 monks live.
And there's no tourists.
And so that's his solution.
But everybody has to
do it a different way.
So you mentioned about
the modern challenges,
and also hopes.
And, on the other
hand, it's a tradition.
Because Zen in such a tradition,
has influenced the very much
by the past.
So did you see, in your
interview, or your observation,
actually, the Zen
Buddhism in China,
they're actually
paying much attention
to revive this
tradition, so the future
is going to look like
their practice is
more traditional, just like
we have read in the books?
Yes.
Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE] in the past.
Yeah I'd say they're very
aware of keeping things simple.
And following the
traditional way of practice
that was developed over
a long period of time.
Every monastery-- a Zen
monastery-- the most important
place is the meditation hall.
And even today, if you
go into a Zen monastery,
and you're a monk, or you're
a nun, you have the right.
Because, if you
live in a monastery,
you have to also do work.
But if you go to
a Zen monastery,
you can go to the meditation
hall and never leave.
You have the right to just
stay in the meditation hall,
and do nothing.
And you're highly respected
for doing that, of course.
Not many people could do that.
So meditation has become
the most important thing
in a Zen monastery.
But right next to that is work.
Everybody has to sweep,
work in the fields--
Communal labor.
That's also, I should mention,
another problem for Zen
monasteries, is because,
during the Cultural Revolution,
and the years that followed, all
of their land was taken away.
Yes.
And the importance of land
is you could grow food,
and support yourself.
If you lose that land,
then you're dependent.
Where are you going
to get the money from?
Well, you get it from donations.
But if you're going to
get it from donations,
you have to open your doors,
and let in pilgrims-- which
is OK-- but tourists,
with bullhorns,
and making a lot of noise.
So that's a big problem is, how
are you going to get your food?
And a lot of Zen
monasteries have
been very successful in
convincing the local government
to give them back some land.
But actually, they
don't give it back.
But you can buy it back.
OK.
Yeah.
And it's very expensive.
It's very expensive.
But they're doing
their best to do that,
because it's really important
to be self-supporting.
And again, the thing that
distinguishes Zen in China
is that it's a way of life.
It's a way of life--
you support yourself.
You get up in the morning,
and you have food.
But then you've got to
go work to get that food.
Instead of going out
and going to a job,
you have a field where you grow
the vegetables, and so forth.
So plant is really important.
That's what Fo Yuan used
to stress at his temple.
He would laugh at people
when they'd come to him
and talk about their problems
with the local governments,
and stuff.
He said, all you have
to do is get land.
If you can just get land,
all your problems are solved.
OK.
I see.
Yeah.
OK.
So in the West, actually, we
get to know about Zen Buddhism
through Japan.
So this varied
pronunciation of Zen
is actually Japanese
pronunciation of Chan.
So according to
your observation,
can you tell the difference
between the Chinese Zen
and Japanese Zen.
So what exactly
things are different?
Of course, the Japanese
Zen originated from China,
in the past.
But right now, do you
have any observations?
Not really, because I've
never been to a Zen monastery
in Japan where I've lived
for a period of time.
I visited them.
So I'm just an outside observer.
I'm a tourist.
So I can't really
speak about it.
But I do know that, from my
superficial view of things,
Zen monasteries
in China and Japan
reflect the personalities
of the two cultures.
The Japanese are
very regimented.
And they love regimentation.
And I like to tell
people-- again,
in a humorous way-- that Chinese
are basically anarchists.
They respect power.
But they would just as soon
be left alone, thank you.
And so, when you go to a
zen monastery in China,
naturally, they have
rules and all this.
But you can, when you're
in the meditation hall,
you can make some noise.
You can adjust yourself.
But in Japan, you get hit.
Exactly.
Also eating.
Everything you do in
a Japanese monastery
is regimented, like
you're in the army.
And in China, it's
much more relaxed.
So how about Taiwan?
You have been living in
Taiwan for such a long time,
and comparing Chinese Buddhism,
Zen Buddhism, in mainland,
and right now looking
back at Taiwan.
Are they moving towards
the Taiwan type of Buddhism
in the future?
Well, they are in
the sense of money.
I think, when I first got
to Taiwan in 1972, people
used to laugh at me for
being a Buddhist-- I mean,
Chinese people.
Because they'd say,
why are believing
in that superstitious nonsense?
But as Taiwan became
wealthy, the Taiwanese people
started expressing their
own religious devotion.
And they started donating money
to these Buddhist temples,
like at Fo Guang Shan.
And they became
incredibly wealthy,
and thus very influential
in the form of Buddhism
that was practiced in
Taiwan, which is mainly
pure land Buddhism-- chanting
the name of the Buddha
to be reborn.
But also, there's some Zen, too.
But when I first got
to Taiwan, in '72,
I only knew of two
Zen masters who
actually had zen monasteries
and small groups of disciples.
There's only a few of them.
Zen has never played
much of a role
in Taiwan, because there's never
been much Buddhism until 1949--
Until the Kuomintang left
China and came to Taiwan.
They brought with them a lot
of very famous Zen masters,
came with them.
But they were all very old.
And so, I visited them
when I first got there.
But they had no following.
The government was
taking care of them.
Everything was OK.
But they were basically
living in an old age home.
Zen had almost no
impact in Taiwan.
Oh, I see.
So the future of Zen is
actually back in China.
Yeah.
Absolutely, I'd say.
So I have one more question.
So that plan, I'm
writing a book which
is entitled How Buddhism
Changed World Civilization.
So it is a book
about the evolution
of Buddhism in India and
China, Tibet, and all
the East Asian countries.
I want to show how
Buddhism actually
impact human civilization in
the past, and the present.
So if I ask the same
question to you.
Do you have an answer?
How are you going to
answer this question?
How Buddhism changed
world civilization?
Well, all I know
is what I've seen.
I can't speak for all of
Southeast Asia, or South Asia.
But from my own
perspective, Buddhism
is almost an enemy
of civilization.
I wouldn't say an enemy, because
that sounds too aggressive.
But civilization, ever
since it's developed,
has seen nothing
but war after war,
after war, aggrandizement
after aggrandizement,
as people try to
control territories.
But Buddhism-- the central
practice of Buddhism--
is one of peace
and non-possession.
So it's like it has--
what shall I say?
It's not a great
supporter of civilization.
That makes sense.
It's not necessarily an
enemy of civilization,
but it's not a great
supporter of civilization.
Because it's about
paying attention
to your own awareness, and
through the cultivation
of wisdom.
But wisdom is based
upon compassion.
And so, the wiser you become
as a Buddhist, the more you
realize that you are one with
all beings-- and especially
your fellow human beings.
So how can you conduct wars?
And how can you base wars based
on possession of territory,
and buildings, and
houses, all this.
So that would be my
answer, is that Buddhism
has had an impact on
civilization in the sense
that it is not supported the
major themes of civilization,
in terms of more and
more, and more, and more.
But Buddhism, in a sense, is
more Taoist-- less and less,
and less, please.
That makes sense.
Yeah.
This is very insightful.
I'm going to write
this into my book.
Well, don't quote me.
Yeah.
OK.
Thank you, Bill, for
spending time with us.
It's a great pleasure
for us to have you, here.
Well, Professor Wu, thank you.
And I hope your
students enjoy this.